one of the world leaders most
prominently denying the reality of
corona virus has been Brazilian
president yayi balsan ro he has now
tested positive for corona virus now
he's 65 years old he has trivialized the
pandemic he would show up places either
without a mask or wearing a mask
incorrectly in terms of total cases in
Brazil now they are second in the you in
the world behind the United States in
terms of total deaths Brazil is now
second in the world behind the United
States in terms of per capita they are
also just below the United States in
both cases and deaths and J herb Olsen
ro was bragging in March that if he were
to get the virus he would quickly fight
it off and recover because he has a
history of being an athlete he then kept
going to large events and to gatherings
without wearing a mask or again wearing
it incorrectly after announcing that he
had tested positive to reporters
yesterday he stepped back and took off
the mask and said look at my face
I feel fine he was also recently with a
bunch of his top cabinet members
everybody was not wearing a mask now I
got messages from people saying you know
David this could be the best thing that
happens to Brazil because this is going
to change bowls inaros
view of coronavirus because he got it
himself I think you're very very wrong
especially if he fights it off he is
going to be reinvigorated about how this
is really no big deal and you know
statistically he's probably going to be
fine because again most people do not
get very sick even 65 year olds who are
generally healthy do not get very sick
here in Massachusetts I believe the
average age of death from corona virus
is like 82 or something like that so in
all likelihood a relatively healthy 65
year old is going to be fine and if he
is and he fights it off
it will actually foment him further
downplaying it with you know see I told
you so it wasn't really serious if he
were to get really sick
it might change his view but this guy
seems so off-the-wall nuts and
disconnected from reality that it might
still not make a difference and when
I was looking online at the comments
about this you know a lot of people
wishing him harm that is never my take I
don't wish harm on anybody I'm
recognizing the propaganda value of this
and he even posted a video yesterday of
himself taking a pill which he claimed
was hydroxychloroquine he was laughing
in the video talking about how great he
feels and how the medication is
certainly working well in blah blah blah
it's all wacky propaganda I mean he
truly seems to have some kind of he has
an unusual personality I don't want to
diagnose anything but it's an unusual
personality now the other thing about
the more prominent people who get
coronavirus is it's believed or let me
put a different way there's speculation
that when a prominent person gets
coronavirus they are immediately getting
access to antibody treatments when we've
seen the success rate of these antibody
treatments where you take convalescent
plasma from people who have recovered
and have antibodies and you transfuse it
into a sick person the reports i've seen
so far are that that is very very
effective and there's speculation I
don't want to say anything other than
there's speculation that when a
prominent or wealthy person gets the
virus they get access to that treatment
which is not widely available because of
the limitations you have to harvest
collect plasma from people who have
recovered and that also may be
increasing the success in fighting off
the virus for prominent or wealthy
people it's mere speculation that's the
latest with the Brazilian President Jo
balsan ara